Bom dia, bom dia ou boa tarde!
Boa tarde, Leo, ou Leonardo, de Lisboa.
- Exatamente.
Aqui já é boa noite.
Ah, já é boa noite.
Bom, vamos falar em português.
Para mim, é uma língua que tenho tentado
aprender e ainda não falo muito bem,
porque é influenciado pelo meu espanhol
e tudo isso.
Não importa, vamos falar hoje.
Leo, ou Leonardo, tem um canal no YouTube.
E vamos deixar todas as...
- Como se diz?
- Os links.
Deixar os links.
- Como se diz?
- Nós dizemos "links".
- Links?
- É, tipo, usamos a palavra inglesa.
A palavra inglesa.
Eu quero falar sobre o português.
Português é uma língua muito interessante,
muito parecida ao espanhol.
Ao galego.
- É uma língua falada no Brasil.
- Sobretudo.
Onde moram como que 200 milhões de pessoas.
E também no país de origem da língua,
Portugal.
Onde moram 10 milhões, acredito,
10 milhões de habitantes.
Que conselho você pode dar às pessoas
que querem aprender português?
Qual é a importância da diferença entre as
duas formas regionais da língua portuguesa?
Assim, o conselho que eu vou dar é...
Contra mim falo,
é uma expressão que se diz, ou seja...
Eu não vou aconselhar aquilo que
a mim me dá mais jeito.
Isso seria, "Aprenda o português europeu."
Eu acho que o melhor conselho
que eu posso dar é...
Na dúvida, aprenda o português brasileiro.
Por duas razões.
A primeira é que a maior parte dos falantes
nativos de português
falam o português brasileiro.
Portanto, a probabilidade de falar
português com um brasileiro
quando se viaja ou quando estamos num
país e conhecemos pessoas nativas
do português de outros países,
a probabilidade de encontrar brasileiros
é muito, muito, muito mais alta do que
a probabilidade de encontrar portugueses.
Portanto, desse ponto de vista,
o português brasileiro é mais útil.
E a segunda razão é que no geral, na média,
o nível de inglês é mais alto em Portugal
do que no Brasil.
Portanto, a probabilidade- É muito mais
necessário saber português no Brasil
do que é necessário saber português
em Portugal.
Portanto, por estas duas razões,
na dúvida...
Ou, assim, se uma pessoa quer aprender
português, só no geral...
Porque quer aprender a língua
e não tem realmente, assim...
Não importa, não lhe interessa muito
nenhum país especificamente,
o brasileiro é uma aposta mais segura.
Claro, se uma pessoa quiser aprender
português porque tem um interesse especial
em Portugal e na cultura portuguesa
ou porque quer vir viver em Portugal,
então aí, já é melhor aprender o português
europeu, porque é o que vai ser mais útil.
Mas claro-
Acho que já sei o que vais perguntar,
e acho que a resposta é...
Quão importantes são essas diferenças
realmente, não é?
Acho que-
Porque é sempre uma pergunta importante.
Assim, sobretudo no início, nada.
Honestamente.
A gramática base é a mesma.
Uma pessoa tem que aprender a língua,
ponto final.
Preocupar-se com a versão é papo,
é preciso aprender a língua.
Depois, mais tarde...
Sobretudo, se começamos a usar a língua
em contexto formal ou contexto informal...
Ou se começamos a estar em
situações culturais
em que a forma de tratamento
pode ser diferente...
Aí sim, já é importante.
Mas para 90% das pessoas que aprendem
o português para se poder comunicar,
é mais importante saber
as palavras, a língua,
do que ter a certeza de que estamos a falar
o português brasileiro e não o europeu.
Ou ter a certeza de que estamos a falar
o português europeu e não o brasileiro.
O que interessa é falar.
A única questão é mesmo situações de
tratamento formal, tratamento informal.
Aí é que já existe um pouco de diferenças
que são importantes.
E se quiseres, eu posso falar delas, Steve.
Queres que eu...?
Meu ponto de vista é o seguinte.
Uma pessoa que mora na Europa,
ingleses ou suecos que querem
viajar para Portugal.
Para eles, acredito que a forma europeia
pode ser mais importante, mais útil.
Então, isso depende de sua vida,
de onde mora.
- Exato.
- Mas é uma coisa.
Outra coisa, a língua ou a forma brasileira
da língua portuguesa
é um pouco mais fácil de entender.
Porque os brasileiros pronunciam
todas as vogais claramente.
As vogais, exatamente.
Então, é um pouco mais difícil, o português
de Portugal é um pouco mais difícil.
Eu, por exemplo, não falo bem em português,
mas entendo quase tudo.
Não quase tudo, mas muito.
E eu tenho escutado muitos podcasts
nos dois.
Nos dois, em português de Portugal
[???] e do Brasil.
Para mim, a coisa mais importante na
aprendizagem de línguas é a compreensão.
Então, eu quero compreender, entender
o português de Portugal e o do Brasil.
É a compreensão.
E quando eu falo,
é possível que eu falo mais como um
espanhol do que qualquer outro.
Mas as pessoas entendem o que eu digo
e eu entendo o que dizem as outras pessoas.
Uma pergunta:
No Brasil, "a gente" quer dizer "nós."
Isso é a mesma coisa em Portugal?
Sim, aqui também.
Se calhar, não se usa com tanta frequência,
mas quando dizemos "a gente", é "nós."
Em espanhol, não.
- "La gente."
- "La gente" é "as pessoas."
- As pessoas.
- Sim.
Aqui, isso é até um erro bastante comum
de quem fala português e já sabe espanhol.
Tanto que aqui- Exato.
Aqui, para dizer "la gente" em espanhol,
para dizer o equivalente,
teria que ser "as pessoas."
As pessoas.
"As pessoas" são "outros."
"A gente" somos "nós."
E no Brasil, também não se usa
a palavra "tu."
Ou no Sul, quem sabe.
Não sei, mas sobretudo, "você."
Em Portugal, tu pode explicar a diferença?
Como se usa o "tu"?
Com que frequência se usa o "tu"?
É similar à situação da Espanha,
onde se usa o "tú" sobretudo?
Como é essa situação?
Isso vai precisamente de encontro ao que eu
estava a dizer há bocado, que é...
Realmente, o que interessa é
aprender a língua.
E as diferenças entre o português de
Portugal e do Brasil são poucas.
Mas no tratamento, existe uma diferença
que, às vezes, é importante saber, que é...
Nós usamos o "tu" basicamente da mesma
forma que se usa o "tú" na Espanha.
Ou na Itália, por exemplo.
Se calhar, se compararmos com a Espanha,
na Espanha, usa-se um pouco mais.
Ou seja, em Portugal...
[???]
Ou seja, em Portugal,
o "tu" é forma informal.
E depois, é terceira pessoa.
Enquanto que "você" é forma formal, pronto.
Se calhar, se compararmos com a Espanha...
Na Espanha,
nós entramos numa loja e dizemos "tú."
A não ser que seja uma pessoa
muito mais velha.
Em Portugal,
entramos numa loja e dizemos "você."
Somos um pouco mais formais com
pessoas desconhecidas.
Mas a lógica é a mesma,
"tu" é informal, "você" é formal.
No entanto, tem um caveat, uma coisinha
que é um pouco mais complicada, que é...
No tratamento formal, usa-se a terceira
pessoa sem dizer a palavra "você."
Ou seja, eu digo-
Eu estou a falar contigo de forma informal.
Mas se estivesse a falar contigo de forma
formal, eu diria "consigo", não "com você."
"Consigo",
"Estou a falar consigo, Steve."
"Steve, o que é que você acha?"
"Steve, não sei o quê."
Ou então, em vez de dizer,
"O que é que você acha?"
Se calhar, diria,
"O que é que o senhor acha?"
"O senhor" é a pessoa com quem
estamos a falar.
Mas não usamos a palavra "você."
O "você" é subentendido,
porque é terceira pessoa.
Mas usamos "o senhor" ou "a senhora."
E usamos "consigo" em vez de "com você."
Pronto, é isto.
Okay, uma outra pergunta.
Leonardo, tu cria conteúdos para
aprender português.
Conteúdos de um nível, mais ou menos,
intermédio.
Qual é a importância para as pessoas que
querem aprender o português
de escutar ou de usar os conteúdos criados
por ti para a aprendizagem do português
se essas pessoas quiserem aprender
o português brasileiro?
Por que é importante?
Eu tenho as minhas opiniões.
É importante também usar os
conteúdos bons do português europeu?
Olha, sabe-se que eu nunca tinha
pensado nisso, mas...
Por que é importante para quem também
aprende o português brasileiro?
Eu acho que, como tu disseste,
em primeiro lugar,
porque se estamos a aprender uma língua, o
primeiro objetivo é entender, compreender.
E portanto, estar expostos à maior
variedade de sotaques
e de versões da língua possível só pode
ajudar, é uma coisa muito positiva.
É importante, mesmo para pessoas que tenham
um interesse no português brasileiro,
é útil ouvir o português europeu,
o português angolano,
o português moçambicano, qualquer que seja.
E a verdade é que a maior parte das coisas
nem são assim tão diferentes.
É português mais do que nada.
Portanto, é mais conteúdo.
E se há uma coisa que acho que nós sabemos,
pessoas como eu e tu que estamos a aprender
línguas na net através de conteúdos online,
é que há sempre falta,
nunca há conteúdo o suficiente.
Portanto, uma pessoa que esteja
a aprender o português brasileiro,
depois de ver todos os vídeos para nível
intermédio de português brasileiro,
vai sempre querer mais conteúdo intermédio.
E portanto, não é nada negativo,
é até bastante positivo
ver o conteúdo para pessoas de nível
intermédio no português europeu.
E vice-versa.
Eu acho que quem aprende o europeu,
também tem que ver conteúdos
em português brasileiro.
Sim, o que precisamos é de conteúdos,
sobretudo conteúdos para nível intermédio.
E quando começamos a aprender uma língua,
qualquer uma, não entendemos a diferença.
Não podemos dizer com certeza se isso é
o português do Brasil ou o de Portugal.
Então, até para um nível bastante alto,
essa diferença não existe.
E quando queremos falar com um sotaque
do Rio de Janeiro ou de Lisboa,
Depois, podemos focar nesse problema
para pronunciar mais como o brasileiro.
Minha experiência é,
se eu vou no Brasil por algumas semanas,
eu vou falar mais como um brasileiro.
E depois, se eu vou em Portugal,
o meu sotaque também vai mudar.
Porque é mais- Eu tenho a impressão que
nossos sotaques são mais flexíveis
quando estamos aprendendo uma outra língua.
Nossa língua nativa não se muda,
mas as línguas que estamos aprendendo
sempre têm a influência das outras pessoas.
Nós somos muito suscetíveis a imitar
a forma da língua que estamos escutando.
Por isso, eu acredito que isso
não tem grande importância.
A importância é os conteúdos interessantes,
conteúdos interessantes e com voz.
Claro que é fácil entender ao escutar.
E como se diz... Vou deixar o link
para que os ouvintes possam usar
o seu conteúdo para aprender português.
- Muito obrigado.
- Seja o português europeu ou o brasileiro.
Muito obrigado por deixar esses meus
conteúdos, por partilhares meus conteúdos.
E sim, eu acho que estamos de acordo nisto.
Não há muito desacordo aqui,
o importante é ouvir.
O importante- É como tu dizes, quando
estamos a começar a aprender a língua
e quando estamos num nível intermédio-
E eu conheço muitas pessoas que falam,
por exemplo, muito bem o inglês.
E mesmo essas pessoas, britânicos,
norte-americanos, australianos,
nem percebem a diferença,
o que interessa é perceber a língua.
- E é isso mesmo.
- Exatamente.
Muito obrigado pela conversa,
foi muito interessante.
Obrigado, Steve.
E espero que façamos isso outra vez também.
Por mim, quando quiseres,
conversamos mais uma vez sobre o português
e sobre línguas, até a próxima, obrigado.
Até a próxima, obrigado.